The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So last time we
were talking about heavy quark
effective theory, and we
phrased several motivations
for talking about heavy quark
effective theory related
to things that we hadn't
seen in effective theory yet.
We also said that
our discussion here
is more general than just
talking about heavy quarks.
Heavy quarks is our
example, but we're really
thinking about having
some very heavy source.
So you can think of it as
either a heavy particle
that you want to
leave in the theory--
So let me rewind.
We talked about heavy particles
already, and what we did
is we integrated them out.
We got rid of them.
But what if you have
a heavy particle,
and you actually
want to study it?
That's related to
this discussion.
That's one way that
this is important.
If you have a heavy
particle that you
want to study at low energies.
Or you could just have a source,
a static source of some quantum
number, in this case, color.
And this would be the right
way of thinking about it.
So those are kind of
some of the motivations,
and then there was also some
more technical motivations
of things that we wanted
to see with this theory.
So we started by saying it's
a top-down approach, so we
should be able to just take QCD
and take the limit and expand.
But it's a little more tricky
than it was so far with, like,
light quark masses for
chiral perturbation theory
because the mass is
in the numerator,
and we want to take the limit
that it goes to infinity, OK?
So we put a question mark
beside this equation,
and we started instead thinking
about expanding the propagator.
So if we write the propagator
out for a heavy quark,
you've got mass terms in the
numerator and the denominator.
And when you expand
it out, after using
the equation of motion
and expanding with
p equals mQ v plus k.
So we introduced a vector,
v. v squared was 1.
And then we introduce
some fluctuations, k.
So there's m's hiding in
this p as well as that p.
The quadratic term in
the denominator cancels.
There's a linear
term that survives.
There's linear terms
in the numerator.
The linear terms, once I
just look at what they give,
they give this
first contribution.
And then there's some
higher-order terms.
Then we drop them.
OK?
So for the propagator we had no
problem taking the heavy quark
limit, and we got
out this expression.
We also then thought
about the vertex.
It's the gluon coupling
to a quark, heavy quark.
And if this is the result in
QCD, this 1 plus v slash over 2
is a projector.
But that means if you square
it, you get back the same thing.
And we said, well, if there's
two propagators on either side
of this thing, I can think
about it putting a projector
on either side of this
thing, and that gives you
this result with just a v mu.
OK?
So the Feynman rule
for this guy can
be simplified by using the
fact that on either side of it
are sitting these projectors.
And if you take those
two facts into account,
we can actually encode
them in a Lagrangian.
We could just write it down, OK?
We want a Lagrangian that
gives that propagator,
the lowest-order propagator,
and that lowest-order vertex.
And that's what this is.
So the v dot D has in it a v dot
A. v dot A is giving this guy.
So that's the v
dot A inside there.
And then 1 over v dot k, that's
the v dot partial, right?
So i v dot D equals
i v dot partial.
I don't know which
sign I'm using here,
but I think it's the minus sign.
AUDIENCE: I think
you're using plus.
PROFESSOR: Using plus?
AUDIENCE: No,
you're using minus.
PROFESSOR: Using minus.
I'll switch
throughout the course.
In each chapter I'll use a
different sign convention
to keep you on your toes.
[CHUCKLES] In this chapter,
I will stick with this sign
convention, since
the source that we're
using for the reading is
using this sign convention.
OK?
So this is the v dot A,
and this is the v dot k
that we have over there.
Now, I've encoded--
the way I encoded
the projection
relation, as I said,
let's work in terms of
a four-component field.
So our field, Qv, still
has four components,
but it satisfies this relation.
And that actually projects
it down onto two components,
and we'll talk more about
what the physics of this
is in a minute.
This is very convenient when
talking about heavy quarks
because you often want to couple
heavy quarks to light quarks,
and if the light quarks
are four-component spinors,
it's easy to couple
them to the heavy quarks
if you have heavy
quark fields which
are four-component spinors.
So you could work in terms of
a two-component Lagrangian that
doesn't have this
projection relation,
but for technical
reasons it's better
to work in terms of
the four-component one.
Makes things simpler.
So that's in some sense
an indirect derivation
of the leading-order
HQET Lagrangian.
Is there any
questions about that?
AUDIENCE: What if you
don't have the propagator
on the other side?
PROFESSOR: What if I
don't have the propagator
on the other side?
Yeah, so we'll talk about
the spinors in a minute,
but it's the same
story for the spinors,
that they have a projection
in relation, which is exactly
the same projection relation.
So whether it's a
line sticking out
or whether it's attached to
something else, it's the same.
OK, so let's now go and derive
the same thing directly.
And the trick we're going
to do is the following.
We need to cancel out this m
in the numerator, and the place
that m hides is in the
p in this formula here.
So if we think about
some field that's
fluctuating in spacetime, we
can pull out from that field
the analog of that big piece,
p, if we pull out a phase
factor that looks like that.
So let me just
write this-- so far
this is just some
redefinition of these objects
on the right-hand side.
And I'm setting up two
objects here because I want--
I'm going to break the field
into these two pieces that obey
different projection relations.
OK?
So if I sum these two
up, the v slashes cancel.
Qv plus-- These are just
two components of the--
I've just split it by two
orthogonal projectors,
two pieces.
And I've pulled out
this piece here.
And the reason that I
pulled out this piece here
is the analog of what
I did here with the p,
where I divided it into a
big piece and a small piece.
This is going to take care of
pulling out that big piece.
OK, so if we want to take the
limit here in this equation.
So far we've written out
what the Q's will be.
We also have to write
out what the D slash is.
So it's convenient to do the
following with the D slash.
Break it into two pieces--
a piece along v and a
piece orthogonal to v.
So the definition
here of D transverse
is that it's D minus
the piece along v,
so if you like that v
dot D transverse is 0.
That's what I mean.
With these relations
up here, there's
also another way of writing
them that I should write down,
as well, which is
a little simpler.
If I rearrange these formulas, I
can also write as v slash on Qv
is Qv, and v slash
on Bv is minus Bv.
So there's a 1 on
this side, and if I
come at it with the
half and put things
together that's what I get.
OK, so let's put those
things together into here,
and then we'll figure out
if we can take the limit.
And the crucial thing,
really, for being
able to take the limit is
to pull out this phase,
and we'll talk about what
physically is happening there
in a minute, once
we've done the algebra.
OK, so just plugging those
pieces together, we have that.
Pull the phase through.
So pull this negative
phase through these terms.
With this v dot D, when
it hits the v dot x,
we get some extra contribution.
And I can group it
together with this mQ term
because what it does is
it brings down an mQ.
The D transverse gives no
derivative, no contribution,
when it hits that phase
because of this relation.
So pulling the phase through,
the only term we pick up
is this minus 1 here.
And I just grouped
it together-- sorry.
The only term we pick
up is this v slash here,
and that comes from this
v dot D hitting that term.
All right?
So now we put these pieces
together, multiply things out,
and use the fact
that I've divided up
the field into these two
pieces that have different--
I know how v slash acts on them,
so I can get rid of all the v
slashes by just
using the formula.
When v minus 1 acts
on Qv, I get 0, OK?
So for that term, for the
term that has two Qv's, I just
have the v slash i v dot D.
You can also prove that when
you have the Qv and the Qv bar
that this term actually is 0,
and to prove that you
basically use the projection
relation and the fact that if
I have 1 plus v slash over 2 D
transverse, that that can
be written as D transverse
1 minus v slash over 2.
Again, using this formula and
the fact that gamma matrices
anticommute.
And then 1 minus v
slash over 2 kills Qv,
and so a term like this one
between these fields is absent,
and the only term with
two Qv's is that one.
Likewise, with Bv's
it's the same story.
I don't get a D transverse term.
But here, the mQ term does
survive, and it doubles,
so the v slash gives
another minus 1,
so there's 2mQ sitting there.
And then there's the
transverse terms,
and they come in
the cross terms.
So Qv Bv.
If I have this, then
this projection relation
won't get rid of it because,
if I have a 1 plus v slash over
2 on the right, it becomes
the correct projector
for the other field on the
left, and then vice versa.
OK?
So there's four terms here, and
we've simplified things as much
as we can.
So now let's think about what
these fields are describing.
In particular, let's
think about what
would happen if we only
had external Qv fields.
So if we consider only
external Qv fields,
then we can think about what
happens as mQ goes to infinity.
And if you have a term--
so as m goes to infinity,
nothing happens to this term.
We have to figure
out what happens
to those terms over there.
But this guy here, it's
clear what happens.
We get a field that has a mass,
mQ, and that particles are just
getting heavier and heavier,
and they're decoupling.
And when you get particles
that get heavy, they decouple.
So Bv decouples in this limit.
So diagrammatically,
think about it like this.
You have a Qv.
It could switch into a Bv with
one of these D slash vertices,
and then back to a Qv, and this
would give some kind of diagram
from this Lagrangian, which
has external Qv fields.
But the Bv field has a 1
over m-type propagator,
and so this goes like 1
over m, and hence goes to 0.
And that's one way of
talking about decoupling,
that intermediate
particles of that type
are giving diagrams that
are suppressed by 1 over m.
OK?
And you see here,
sitting right here,
you see our Lagrangian
that we want,
which is the Qv i v dot D Bv.
So if we just threw
away the Bv fields,
we would get the
Lagrangian that we want.
So physically what's going
on with these two fields
is that Qv corresponds
to the particles, OK?
We have a heavy quark.
It's got particles that are of
that mass and that flavor that
are heavy, and it has
antiparticles, too.
Qv corresponds to the
particles, and Bv corresponds
to the antiparticles.
So-- of this flavor.
And by making the phase
redefinition that we did,
we chose to focus on
on-shell fluctuations that
are close to the particles.
If we'd chosen the
opposite phase, plus i,
then we could expand
about the antiparticles,
and things would have
worked out the opposite way.
So I'll come back to that a
little bit more in a second.
So let's have several
discussion points here.
So what we did is we made
a field redefinition, which
we were always allowed to do.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Isn't Qv
like a [INAUDIBLE]
eigenstate of positive helicity?
And the other one--
PROFESSOR: We're talking
about heavy particles,
so helicity is not
such a good thing to--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I'll talk
more about it in a sec.
Yeah.
Yeah, give me a minute,
and then if you still
have a question after I
talk about it, then ask.
So first of all, what we
did here was tree level.
OK?
So when we make this
type of redefinition
and we go through this
algebra, it's all tree level.
Not thinking about
any loops here.
There will be
corrections to this story
once we start
talking about loops,
and there will be
corrections to this story,
namely that we
just get the same L
HQET once we want to take
into account one of our m
corrections, and will come
back to both of those points.
So both of those things
to be discussed later.
What we do do with L HQET--
as we described
correctly, the couplings
to gluons at leading order.
And often what people are
interested in with k mu here
is k mu of order lambda QCD,
separating the scale lambda
QCD that has to do with the
confinement into a meson,
like a B meson, from the
scale of the heavy quark.
OK, so the antiparticles
are being removed,
which is point number 2.
So if you want to ask what is
it that we're integrating out
in this theory, we're not
integrating out the particle,
because we want to study it.
We're integrating
out the antiparticle.
It's easiest to see that if
you go to the rest frame.
So taking v rest frame,
which is just 1, 0, 0, 0,
just timelike component, then
our 1 plus v slash becomes a--
so if you have 1 plus v
slash, then that's just 1
plus gamma 0 over 2.
And if you want to talk about
particles and antiparticles,
the best representation to use
is the Dirac representation
because then the particles--
So let's take a spinor in
the Dirac representation.
Could be part of this field.
Could just be a spinor
for an external state.
In the Dirac
representation, what
happens is that you
have the guys that
are the particles in
the upper two components
and the guys that are the
antiparticles in the lower two
components.
So this is particles.
This is antiparticles.
This guy is always
projecting in the rest frame
into the particles
and antiparticles.
It's just that if you read
in other representations
you'd have more
trouble seeing that,
but in the Dirac representation
we just have a 0, OK?
So this is one way of
thinking about what
this projector is doing.
It's getting rid of
the antiparticles.
So the way you should
think about this physically
is that, if you're
studying some process,
you're studying heavy particles
close to their mass shell.
What we're doing is we're
measuring fluctuations
near the heavy mass, mQ.
We're perturbing about mQ.
If you're perturbing about
mQ, the antiparticles
are very far away because the
splitting between the particles
and the antiparticles is 2mQ.
So that's why they
get integrated out.
So that's why, in this
language of being near mQ,
the antiparticles are
just very far away,
and we don't want
them in our theory.
One way of talking about
that is pair creation.
So if we draw some type of
Time-Ordered Perturbation
Theory diagram for
pair creation--
so it's not a Feynman diagram,
but a TOPT diagram, just so we
can talk about a definite
intermediate state
at a definite time, then
this intermediate state here
has three heavy
particles, and it has--
If this guy has mQ and this
guy has mQ, this guy has 3mQ.
So this intermediate
state is off-shell by 2mQ.
Time-ordered perturbation
theory diagram.
So I can talk about whether
something is definitely
a particle or definitely
an antiparticle.
And another way of seeing this
2mQ that I'm talking about
is, like, just to do
vacuum polarization, where
you have 2mQ.
You need 2mQ of energy to
fluctuate into a heavy quark
pair.
So we have a very light
gluon, and it just
doesn't have the
energy to do that,
so pair creation is not
part of this theory, OK?
So now you can ask your question
if you still have a question.
[CHUCKLES] Yeah.
All right?
So the thing we're getting
rid of is the antiparticle.
Now, because we're getting
really antiparticle,
we no longer have an
annihilation process.
So unlike QCD,
where you can have
particles and
antiparticles annihilate,
here we have actually
a conservation rule
for the number of
heavy particles.
We're talking here about quarks.
The number of heavy
quarks is preserved,
and that's an extra
symmetry that this theory
has that QCD didn't have.
OK?
So the conservation law for the
number of heavy quarks is u1.
More generally,
we can extend this
to something called
heavy quark symmetry.
So let's-- since we notice that
there's this conservation law,
let's think about what the
biggest group we can come up
with is that describes the
symmetry of this L HQET.
So this u1 that preserves
the heavy quarks
is a flavor symmetry.
And depending on how many
heavy particles we have,
it could be bigger than a u1.
So actually, it's a uNh
for Nh heavy quarks.
So you could have
some heavy sources
that live under some group.
And if you have N
types of those sources,
you'd have a uN symmetry.
And the root of this is
that we got rid of mQ.
mQ was the thing that
would break this symmetry,
but it disappeared.
And once it's gone,
we don't care.
We don't know whether the
thing was a charm quark or a B
quark or a top quark.
We don't see the
flavor of the quark
anymore because
the mass term was
what was tracking that
flavor, and now it's gone,
and we just end up
with this theory that
doesn't remember
about the flavor,
so we have a flavor symmetry.
OK?
So that's kind of
cool as an example
of having an effective
theory where there's
an emergent symmetry,
symmetry that
wasn't so apparent in the
theory you started with but is
apparent once you get
to the effective theory.
The other example
is spin symmetry.
There's actually an
su2 spin symmetry
because the Lagrangian didn't
involve any D slashes anymore.
It just became scalar,
the v dot D. So
if we think about
our heavy part--
so we think about a
four-component spinor.
Two degrees of freedom
have to do with particle
versus antiparticle.
The other two have to
do with spin, a half.
And we don't care
about the spin,
either, because our Lagrangian
is completely scalar.
OK?
We just had Qv i v dot
D Qv, and there was no--
we didn't mention-- the v dot
D doesn't have any D slash.
It doesn't have any
spin matrices in it, OK?
So that's an su2 symmetry.
So if we want to talk
about that again,
it's useful to think about
it in the rest frame.
In the rest frame, the heavy
quark spin transformation.
Need some Dirac
representation, which is gamma
phi, gamma 0, gamma i.
It's just the Pauli
matrices, sigma i.
And you could think of making
a transformation related
to the spin.
So the infinitesimal version
of that transformation
would look like this.
Start with Qv.
Do a rotation.
Ask, does this change
the Lagrangian?
And the statement
is that it changed
the Lagrangian
that you get, which
is i v dot D commutator
i epsilon dot sQ.
But i v dot D is just this
scalar quantity and just
commutes through this
epsilon dot sQ, OK?
So that's the formal statement
that there's a spin symmetry.
Since we're using this kind
of projected formalism,
you could ask the
question, well,
maybe this spin symmetry is
mixing up the heavy quark
components with the
other components,
these zero components, but
you can check that it doesn't.
It's actually acting within
the subcategory, which is just
describing the heavy quark.
So you can also check it.
One way of phrasing
that is that you
can check that this is true.
So that the rotated field
still satisfies the projection
relation.
So really, this is
a rotation that's
within the two-component
subspace that
are describing the physical
degrees of freedom.
OK?
So there's this enhanced
symmetry group of this theory.
And we can put it together
because nothing stops us
from doing this, or doing
this, or doing a bit of both,
so we can build one big group.
So all together,
you have a u2Nh,
and that's heavy quark symmetry.
A Qv field is a
fundamental in that group.
So [INAUDIBLE] spinors
look like this,
with some number of components,
and this guy could be--
for example, maybe this
is a B quark with spin up.
And then some other
component might
be a charm quark with spin up
or a B quark with spin down.
That's what heavy
quark symmetry is.
OK?
So any questions about that?
So we'll talk a bit more
about how you actually
make predictions related to
this heavy quark symmetry.
As you saw, it's
kind of emergent,
and so you should
build some tools
for seeing what kind of impact
that has on observables,
and we'll spend a little bit
of time doing that today.
But before we do that,
let's continue our list.
So when we made this
field redefinition,
we pulled out this phase,
and that phase depended on v.
And we also stuck a
label v on the field.
So we had this v mu, which
appeared on our field, OK?
And that was just a
reminder that we pulled out
a phase, and the phase
depending on our choice of v,
and we could make actually
different choices.
This v mu is actually
something quite useful
because it isn't changed when
you talk about low-energy QCD
interactions.
So it's a conserved quantity.
So in our notation of
dividing up p into mQv plus k,
this changes.
So if you tickle with very
soft gluons the heavy quark,
you can't change this term,
but you can change that term.
So the v term is not affected
by the gluon interactions.
It's a conserved
quantity, and hence
having it as a
label on our field
tells us what v
we're talking about.
Basically, what v
signifies is you
could talk about a heavy
quark in its rest frame,
and then you could
talk about tickling it.
Or it could be moving with
some constant velocity,
and you could talk about that
moving frame tickling it.
And any such choice
is equally valid,
and that's what v is encoding.
OK?
But we can formulate tickling a
heavy quark in any given frame
that we'd like, and
v is encoding that.
Things are kind of natural
to see in the rest frame,
but we don't have to
work in the rest frame,
and that's what v is encoding.
OK?
So that's kind of different
than we've seen before.
What's the power counting?
Power counting is not
so difficult here.
It's just powers of 1 over mQ.
So our leading-order
Lagrangian had
no mQ's and then we could
formulate corrections
to that leading order, and
they would be suppressed
by powers of 1 over mQ.
So let's think about that
in a little more detail.
So if you take the field Q
of x and you write the mode
expansion for the field--
but there's this
term, and then there's
a term that involves
the antiparticles.
What we did with
the Q of x field--
that's the full theory field--
is we pulled out this phase.
And the phase that we
pulled out was just
something that depended
on a fixed quantity, m v,
so it would come
outside that integral.
So we pulled out--
so you can think about
really literally sticking p
into this formula and then
pulling out that phase.
And then that leaves, in Q v,
just the e to the minus i k dot
x.
OK?
So if you think about
derivatives on Qv of x,
then they are scaling like k.
And this guy here
has no mQ's in it.
So there's no mQ's
in the derivatives.
So if we build operators
out of this Qv field,
if we let derivatives
act on that field,
there's no factors of the heavy
quark mass hiding anywhere
in those derivatives.
That's the magic of making this
kind of phase redefinition.
We've made the mQ's explicit
by pulling that out so that we
could get something remaining
that doesn't have any mQ's.
Since we want to count
mQ's what we want to do
is we want to make all the
mQ's very, very explicit.
We don't want any to
be hiding anywhere,
and that's what we were
doing before with this field
redefinition, was making
all the mQ's explicit.
This is one example of
why that's important.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you should-- if you
think about the action--
yeah, if you think
about the action
and you thought about making
a gauge transformation,
you could worry about making
a gauge transformation that
would inject too much
momentum into your field
so that it no longer described
low-energy degrees of freedom.
But usually people don't talk
about that so much in HQET,
so we'll save that
discussion for [INAUDIBLE],,
but we will have it.
So the coordinate, x-- one way
of thinking about this equation
is that the coordinate
x that's in Qv really
corresponds to variations that
are the low-energy variations.
So our field is
doing what we want.
It's describing
low-energy fluctuations.
And that's another way of
thinking about the fact
that there's no mQ's
in this derivative.
So if we look at
subleading operators and--
if we look at
subleading Lagrangians
and external operators,
all the powers of m Q
are going to be
explicit, and that
makes doing the power counting
quite simple because we just
look at them and count.
So as long as we're sure
that they're all explicit
and none are hiding anywhere,
then it's easy to count.
There will be logs of mQ
hiding in Wilson coefficients,
but we're not counting logs.
If we're just counting
powers, then what I said
is sufficient, OK?
So is there any
questions about that?
So there's actually
one mQ that's hiding,
and we should be a little
bit careful about it.
So if we talk about
states, there's
actually an mQ hiding in there.
So let's think about states
of some particle that's
relativistically normalized.
It could be a heavy meson.
Let me just call it H. And
the usual normalization
convention for a
relativistic particle
is this one for the states.
So this guy, if you
look at the dimensions
of the right-hand
side here, you've
got minus 3 plus 1 is
minus 2, so each of these
is dimension minus 1.
So that's one thing
we can [INAUDIBLE]..
But if you think
about what this Ep is,
this Ep has the M
still hiding in it.
So this Ep is really the
physical on-shell energy,
so it's mQ squared.
If this was a heavy
hadron, for example,
it'd be mH squared plus
the 3-momentum squared.
And mH, for a heavy hadron,
has an mQ hiding in it.
OK, so what we have to do if
we want to make everything
explicit is use HQET states.
And you can think of HQET
states simply as the states
that you get if you
define your quantum field
theory using L HQET.
So this is the mQ
goes to infinity,
so it's just the
leading-order term.
And if you define your
states with this Lagrangian,
you can still talk about a
bound state like the B meson.
Because the B quark
didn't go away.
It just became static.
And all the dynamics of the
light degrees of freedom
that are making it into
a hadron are still there,
and they're described by
a usual QCD Lagrangian.
So you still have hadrons,
so you still have a B meson,
but it's not the same because
you don't have any mQ's.
They're all gone.
So you can't possibly have this
formula for the HQET definition
of the state.
And so the way that you
should think about this
is that the relativistic
version of the state
is related to the
HQET definition
by a formula like this.
So the HQET
definition is this Hv,
the relativistic is this Hp.
And there's some normalization
factor between them,
and as well as there can be
1 over M type corrections.
Actually, both things are there.
And if we talk about
this H v field,
where v is some external
label telling us the velocity
and k is describing
some residual momentum
of that state, the
normalization convention
would be as follows for HQET.
So I've still left it to be 2.
Sometimes people to
remove this 2, as well.
So there's several
things going on here.
One is that v and v prime--
in order for these
states to have overlap,
we're saying that you should be
talking about hadrons that are
moving with the same velocity.
Remember velocity is
conserved, so if we
had two things in
different sectors,
they just wouldn't overlap.
That's [INAUDIBLE] of delta.
This delta 3 of k
minus prime is exactly
the analog of this
guy over here,
but now it's with the k,
which is the residual.
It has no mQ's.
And I got rid of the mQ--
I got rid of the thing
in the numerator that
was pulling out this root mH.
So there's no mQ's
in that formula,
and that's the right
way of thinking.
So you have to
remember, if you have
some formula for
the cross-section
that you derived with
relativistic states, which
all of the formulas you're
used to are derived that way,
you have to remember
about that root of H
when you're going to make
predictions with HQET.
And the same thing actually
is true of the spinors.
There's a square root of the
quark mass hiding in spinors,
and you have to take
care of that, as well.
I'll leave that
for your reading.
OK?
So up to these little
subtleties here, that's
all the mQ's that you
have to keep track of,
and once we've kept track
of all those mQ's, then
we know how to do the power
counting in this theory.
What can we do with the theory?
Well, one thing that
we can do immediately
is do some spectroscopy.
So this will actually show us
partly what kind of predictions
we can make from symmetry.
So there's light
quarks and gluons,
and they are still
described, as I said in words
but now I write on the
board, by a full L QCD.
Nothing changes.
There was no heavy quark
masses in that anyway,
so nothing happens to that,
at least for what we're
talking about here.
There could be some
loop corrections, but--
So if we think about
mQ going to infinity,
we can ask what happens
to these hadrons, which
I've just told you you can
still describe by the theory.
So if you think about a Q and a
light quark, which is a meson,
it has the quantum numbers
of the heavy quark.
And remember that the
number of heavy quarks
is conserved in this limit.
And then it has
the quantum numbers
of the rest of the stuff,
which could be an antiquark.
It could be any number
of Q q bar pairs
because we don't know
how many are there.
We have nonperturbative
interactions.
And it could have
any number of gluons.
And generically, we call this
stuff light degrees of freedom
because that's what it is.
This is heavy.
This is light.
And it's just a
bunch of light stuff.
OK?
So that's kind of how we
can think of the state.
It's a bunch of-- it's
an infinite number
of single particle states
because it's a complicated QCD
bound state.
And what we want
to do is we want
to sort of enumerate what
symmetry can tell us.
Well, since we have the--
we can think about
total angular momentum,
and that is actually
a good quantum number.
It was in QCD, and it
remains true in HQET.
The thing that's new is that the
heavy quark spin is conserved.
So SQ is conserved.
And that we can use
to say something
more about the states.
And usually the way
that this is done
is by defining Sl
to be J minus SQ.
So if both J and SQ are
good things to talk about,
we can also talk about Sl,
which is the difference.
And if you want to think
of quantum numbers here,
then J squared, right, would be,
in terms of quantum numbers, so
J, J plus 1.
And so we can do the same
thing with Sl [INAUDIBLE] Sl,
Sl plus 1.
On a state with good
quantum numbers of Sl.
So if we organize
things in terms of Sl,
then we get symmetry
doublets for the mesons.
So let's pick an Sl and some
parity, make a little table.
If we take a 1/2 minus,
there's two mesons
that fall in that camp, a B
and a B star that have little--
just call it capital J.
Let me call it little j.
j is 0 and 1 for these guys.
So this is the scalar guy,
and this is a vector guy.
And the parity is negative,
so it's a pseudoscalar.
We can keep enumerating.
There's a guy with
opposite party.
These guys turned
out to be heavier.
This is the lightest
ground-state heavy mesons.
3/2 plus called B1 and B2 star.
All these things
have been observed.
And you could keep
going, and you could
do the same thing for baryons.
So if you do baryons,
then the spin
of the light degrees
of freedom are not
half-integer, but integer.
0 plus is just the lambda B,
and then the only possible j
is to add 1/2 for the SQ.
So what's happening
is this is Sl,
and then remember that the
Lagrangian and the dynamics
is independent of SQ.
So I can add and subtract
the SQ from this Sl,
and I get total j of 0 or 1,
but the dynamics of these mesons
doesn't care about
the heavy quark spin,
so that's why they come
in a symmetry doublet.
So the heavy quark spin
symmetry is relating things
in a doublet of given Sl.
That's how you should--
AUDIENCE: Notion to star just
always mean excited [INAUDIBLE]
state?
PROFESSOR: Star
is just another--
star is just something you can
put on the B to make it not
look like a B. [CHUCKLE]
You could put a twiddle--
I mean, generically, it started
out as star being the vector.
Star is like kind of a
notation for vectors.
But then, of course, here
B0 star is a scalar, so--
[CHUCKLES]
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So we have the lambda B, and
then here we have sigmas.
That's telling us that we're
already making some predictions
about mesons, and
baryons, for that matter,
just from symmetry.
Now, if you want to
really make predictions,
you'd like to look at
a little more dynamics,
and for that there's
something that's
kind of cool called using
a covariant representation
of fields.
So I want to show
you how that works.
So we're going to see how
to make heavy quark symmetry
predictions by building
up some object that has
good transformation properties.
And this is in general something
that's a more general lesson.
If you have a
symmetry, and you want
to make some predictions
that are just
based on that
symmetry, then you want
to think about how
things transform,
and you can do tricks like the
ones I'm going to show you.
So we're going to
encode heavy quark
symmetry in objects with nice
transformation properties.
The moral of this story is that
it's much easier to take traces
than to think about
Clebsch-Gordan coefficients.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: The way you've
done it so far, when
you throw in this v,
should I be worried
that you've broken [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Angular momentum is conserved.
It's the boosts that are broken.
But we'll talk
about-- we're going
to come to that in a minute.
Yeah, yeah.
But the ang--
I mean, good question
related to this discussion.
The angular momentum
is actually conserved.
Yeah.
OK.
But rather than try to make
this a kind of derivation,
I'm going to just
tell you the answer,
and then we'll talk
about its properties.
So I'm going to write
down a field that
annihilates the meson doublet
for the ground-state mesons.
Q is the heavy quark flavor.
pv mu star Q is something
that annihilates
a vector, B star-type meson.
So Q could be charm, as well.
And pv without the mu is
annihilating the B meson
if Q was B. This is
the flavor, which
you can think of as for this
discussion bottom or charm.
And so this guy is a bispinor.
It's got the indices
of Q q bar, but it's
turned a vector field
and a pseudoscalar field
into a bispinor.
This thing here, this
1 plus v slash over 2,
is projecting out the heavy
quark degrees of freedom.
This is a vector.
So this is like something
that, if you acted on a state,
would get replaced
by the polarization.
Epsilon squared is minus
1, and v dot epsilon is 0,
so that means that v
dot this guy is also 0.
And this is pseudoscalar.
So this is the vector meson.
This is the pseudoscalar.
So what are the transformation
properties of this?
So it's a bispinor.
If you do a Lorentz,
it transforms
like a bispinor should under
a Lorentz transformation.
This is a spinor
Lorentz transformation,
and v prime is the
transformation of v,
and x prime is the
transformation of x.
So that's how we
want it to transform.
We want something that has--
it's transforming
like this Q q bar.
We've got v slash
on Hv equals Hv.
That's one way of writing
this 1 plus v slash over 2Hv
is equal to Hv.
And that says that there's
no antiquark, so that's good.
We can also, just by studying
the properties of this thing,
work out that Hv B slash
is actually minus Hv.
That one is not
something we built in.
That's an outcome.
So you could work this out,
so I won't go through it.
You just push it
through the other side,
and you can figure
out that that's true.
So we'll use it, but
it's not something
that directly-- it's an outcome
of putting things together,
not so much something
that we built in.
If we talk about heavy quark
and light quark symmetries,
so SQ cross Sl, then
it's 1/2, 1/2 under that.
So if we work in the rest
frame, which is this vr, which
is 1, 0, then you have--
if you think about doing
a symmetry transformation,
you get a commutator,
and basically
what happens is
that you would get--
you have two sets of--
you have a bispinor,
so you have two parts
of the spinor that
are corresponding to the
heavy quark and two parts that
are corresponding
to the light quark.
The heavy quark
part is on the left,
and then the light quark
part is on the right.
That's the spin transformations.
And this is the right spin
transformation for something
that's spin 1/2,
where the sigma 4 by 4
is the usual spin matrix.
Let me just say a bit more
about heavy quark spin
symmetry, which is part
of our discussion there.
So Hv is transforming.
If you do a heavy quark spin
symmetry transformation,
it's transforming on the left.
That's what I just
was discussing.
And if you do some
transformation parameterized
by some theta, which I just
dot into the S over there,
then this is the way
we think about what
the transformation gives.
So you could take this, and
you could plug in our Hv field
and then just do
the Dirac algebra
with the gamma and the gamma
5 and simplify this thing down
and work out a transformation
for delta pv and delta pv star.
And what you'd find is that this
guy in the rest frame here--
everything in the rest frame is
that, and this guy, theta cross
pvr star minus 1/2 theta pvr.
So if you talk about
the transformations
under heavy quark spin
symmetry of the states,
these are actually getting
mixed up into each other.
And that's what we
already were saying
before when we were
talking about spectroscopy,
that spin symmetry
was relating the two.
This is us now seeing
that very explicitly,
that if you make a heavy quark
spin symmetry transformation,
the vector guy--
so this guy should have a star--
and the scalar guy get mixed up.
And that's what spin
symmetry allows you to do,
is relate any
statements about the v
to statements about the v star.
It's one thing it
allows you to do.
So the power of
this Hvr thing is
that it allows us to make
heavy quark spin symmetry
predictions easily
because we've encoded
the symmetry in this object.
Kind of like our
spurion analysis,
we'll be able to use
similar types of ideas
to make spin symmetry
predictions easy with this guy.
So let me give you
an example of that.
So an example is talking about
heavy quark decay constants.
And we can think about
B mesons or D mesons.
Correspondingly, B
stars and D stars.
So think of the Q field here
that I'm writing as a full QCD
field, and the p field
here with momentum p,
it's either a B
meson or a D meson.
And just by Lorentz
symmetry, much like one
works out for the pion,
one can write down
a result that just falls from
Lorentz invariance and parity
for what the result
for this coefficient
is, because you also have
to use time reversal.
And you could also
write the p as mp times
v if you want to make
explicit that there's
some velocity that this
thing, that this p squares
to the mass of that state.
So this guy here is some
dimension 1 constant.
And if we just, in
QCD, do the same thing
for the other guy,
which is the vector,
we can do the same game.
Here we have to
get a polarization
on the right-hand side.
There has to be linear
in the polarization.
That's the statement
about a vector.
And because of parity, it's
not the gamma mu, gamma phi,
but the gamma mu that
comes in because we
have spin 1 instead of spin 0.
So there's an extra
minus 1 from that.
So instead of-- so we
have a gamma mu here,
and this is how we can
parameterize the matrix
element.
And this guy here, if we
work out the dimensions,
it would be dimension 2.
So just in QCD, it
looks like we have
these two things, fp and fp
star, that are different.
But we know heavy quark symmetry
relates the p and the p star,
so they actually
should be related.
So you could ask the question,
how are they related?
Work it out.
And if I asked you
that question, the way
to work it out, which I'll show
you, is to use this Hv field.
OK, so there's two things
we have to work out.
We have to-- we're going
to use the Hv field.
I'll show you how.
We also have to think
about these currents
that I've talked about here and
writing them in terms of the Qv
field, so let's do that first.
So that's pretty easy.
Just replace our
field by the Qv field.
Now, if I just want to make
a statement about heavy quark
symmetry, then I can look
at how this guy transforms
under heavy quark
symmetry because I
know how Qv transforms
under heavy quark symmetry.
So [INAUDIBLE] D.
And so what I'd like
to do is I'd like
to encode in a general object--
much as we did in chiral
perturbation theory,
I'd like to encode in a general
object that involves the Hv
field something that has
the same transformation
properties as this current.
Much in the same way we
could think about putting--
connecting currents that
transformed in a certain way
to a chiral theory, we're
doing the same thing
with heavy quarks.
So let's pretend--
in order to do this,
instead of thinking
about covariance,
we'd want to think
about invariance.
So pretend that the Dirac
structure transforms such
that we cancel that D.
Then we have an invariant,
and we can think about building
invariance out of the Hv field.
And it's very simple because
if we think about that,
gamma times Hv is invariant.
You only have to think
about one Hv field
because the number of
heavy quarks is preserved.
OK?
So we know there's only one,
and then the other thing that
transforms is to gamma.
And so that we can form
an invariant, which
is gamma H. So then if
you look at this thing--
and then the sandwiching
with this guy--
the indices of--
So this guy's got
a vector index,
and this guy's got
a scalar index,
but that's all encoded
in our Hv field, right?
It's got indices
for those fields.
So we're basically
constructing things--
we're just basically
constructing--
if we've already
accounted for the indices
here on the left-hand
side of the equation,
then we're just constructing
things that are scalars.
So Lorentz covariance
requires us
to take a trace to get a scalar,
and so we basically have trace.
We can put anything
we like here.
And then we have gamma Hv, which
is like the QCD stuff, and then
the heavy quark part.
So we just have to write
down the most general
x that we can think of.
And there's not
that much we can do
because there's not that
many vectors available to us.
So there's two things
that we can do.
We can write down something
that just is a diagonal
or something that's a v slash.
But then we can
simplify this guy
because Hv v slash is minus Hv.
See, I can take this,
and this is a trace,
so I can move it over to
the other side of the trace,
and if it's a v slash on
then I can use this formula.
And so these two guys
here actually just become,
after taking that into account,
one thing, which I'll just call
a.
So there's basically
a unique thing
that we can write
down for the x.
After we use all the symmetry
properties of the Hv,
we only have one thing.
And so then you can just
work out what that trace is.
Just take the trace.
And you get a, and you
get minus i v mu pv,
or you get pv star mu,
and this is what you get
if you have gamma mu, gamma 5.
And this is what you get
if you have gamma mu,
and if you have the other way--
so for gamma mu, you don't
get any pseudoscalar,
and for gamma mu gamma 5,
you don't get any vector.
So the way that you
should think about this
is that in the matrix element
and only in the matrix element,
but between these
ground-state mesons,
I can really think that I've
made some connection that
looks like as follows.
That Q gamma H v--
sorry, Qv is a over 2 times
this trace of gamma Hv
if I'm in the matrix element.
And then I know how to
take matrix elements
with these fields
because they're
the fields that actually are
annihilating those states.
So then Q bar gamma
mu, gamma 5, capital
Q. Now I'm using HQET states.
They're actually
annihilating HQET states.
And I just use the formula
that I've derived over there.
And I get these two results.
So for HQET states, I
have only one constant, a.
And that's because
heavy quark symmetry
related the decay constants.
And if I look at
all the dimensions
of the things on this
side and count them up,
I find that the
dimensions here are
such that this
would be something
that's lambda QCD to the 3/2.
So then I can try to go back and
connect to my decay constants
what this a is.
And we know how to do
that because I told you
how to connect
the states, and we
talked about how to connect the
currents, which is very simple.
These states here are
dimension minus 3/2,
and that's basically what
leads to the different power
on the right-hand side.
So connect the states.
That gives some extra
factors of meson masses,
and we find that fp is
this universal constant,
a over square root
mp, and fp star is
this a times the
square root of mp star,
and then we're getting
correctly the dimension 2
or the dimension 1 quantities
in terms of one universal a, OK?
So you can make
predictions from this.
So for example, you could take
fB, and you could say, well,
how big should fB be?
Well, it should be, by
dimensional analysis,
now that we've figured out how
to do dimensional analysis,
it should be of this size.
And that gives you something
that's not too far off.
Or you could take fB over
fD, and you could predict--
because actually we
don't care whether it's
a charm quark or a B quark.
The a here didn't care about the
flavor of the p and the p star
state.
So everything I said here
could apply equally well
to B states or D states.
So if we make--
so the only place
that it's coming in
is when we have this
explicit square root here.
And just by power counting,
we should say fB over fD
is like mD over mB,
which is about 0.6.
OK?
So these are predictions that
we can make based on symmetry.
And then if you have a
prediction based on symmetry,
you could also talk about
symmetry-violating corrections,
and people do that
kind of thing to make--
a is the lowest
prediction, but you
could talk about violating it
with some higher-order a's, and
those type of things are done.
The real place that this
gives a lot of power,
I have to mention,
although we'll not
talk about it in
detail, is when you
look at semileptonic decays.
So if you look at the
semileptonic decay
of a transition of
a B meson into a D,
or a B meson into
a D star, then you
can again use all
these symmetry tricks
and again use this H v field--
and some of the
reading will talk
about this, these weak decays.
If you were to enumerate
the number of form factors
you'd have in QCD, you'd
have six form factors.
And once you go over to
the heavy quark limit,
there's just one.
And it's actually
normalized, too,
because it's related
to a conserved charge.
[INAUDIBLE] spin
symmetry to relate it.
You could use your heavy
quark spin symmetry
to actually relate it to the--
the operator that counts
the number of B quarks.
So these form factors,
you don't know anything
about their normalization.
There's six of them.
Take this limit, you get
one, and it's normalized.
It's kind of nice.
It's called the
Isgur-Wise function.
AUDIENCE: I have
a quick question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you
said that that [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Why did I say that?
So for example,
imagine that I was
to have done this for
not the p and the p star,
but for these other
things that I was calling
B0 and B1, or B1 and B2.
Then when I would
go through it, I
would have not
used the Hv field.
I would have had to
build a field that
has those guys in it, which
would have spin 1 and spin 2.
And that would be a
different matrix element.
I can still do the
whole same story,
but really, this formula,
this particular version
of the current, is only
true for these states,
and for other states you'd have
to use a different version.
That's what I meant.
Any other questions?
OK, so I want to just, in
remaining two minutes, get
started on something else
that I'd like to talk about,
which is related to the
question that we left aside,
and that is, what about
alpha s corrections?
And there's a couple of things
here that are interesting.
But basically, it
boils down to--
We've already seen how to do
matching and normalization
group evolution, but now
we have these extra labels,
and so we can ask, what
impact does having labels
on that whole story of matching
and normalization group
evolution, what
impact does it have?
And we'll say that
there are examples
where it does have an impact.
So--
HQET radiative corrections.
So if you like,
we're just thinking
about the renormalization,
as we should
for any effective theory,
think about what's
the renormalization structure.
And since it's a top-down, we
can also think about matching.
So we should think
about renormalization
of L. We should think
of external currents,
like the ones we
were talking about over there.
And if we match a
full theory current,
the way that you should
think about what's
happening from matching
is that there'll
be some Wilson coefficient
that's generated
by radiative corrections.
So once we think about
adding alpha s corrections
to our story, there
could be radiative
corrections and Lagrangians--
we'll talk about that.
But there also are nontrivial
radiative corrections here
in the currents, where they get
multiplied by something that
depends on virtual
interactions having
to do with antiparticles
that we're integrating out,
and that just affects
these currents,
the current relations,
by multiplying them
by some coefficients.
Yeah.
So the first thing
that actually differs,
and it's because, again,
there's no antiparticles--
that changes the nature
of loop diagrams--
is the wavefunction
normalization.
So we have to go
through that again.
So if we do field
renormalization,
it's the same kind of
story as it is in QCD.
We have to consider
this diagram,
but we have to calculate
it now in HQET.
So let there be some external--
I'll call it p.
I should call it k.
Call it k.
There'll be some loop
momentum, and we have q plus k.
If we use dimensional
regularization,
then this loop integral
looks like this.
So using [? m ?] [? s ?] bar,
there's some usual [? m ?]
[? s bar-type ?] factors.
And then there's the
relativistic propagator,
which I'm using Feynman
gauge, so it's just q squared,
and then there's the heavy
quark propagator, which
would look like that.
So the loop integral
that I have to do here
wouldn't have two
relativistic propagators.
It has one heavy
quark propagator
and one relativistic
propagator, and it
will give something
different, and we'll
talk about it in more detail
next time, about evaluating
this loop integral.
So I wanted to do one
loop integral for you.
And basically the way I'm
going to talk about these,
the renormalizations
and matching,
is I'll do this loop
integral for you
so you have some idea what would
be involved if I was asking
you to do them yourself, which
I don't think I'm going to do.
And then I'll just be
quoting results for you
and telling you kind of how the
structure of the theory looks
and where the corrections
are going and talking
about the important things
that come out of the results,
rather than dwelling on
calculational details.
But we will talk
about one calculation
because there's one trick that
you should know if you ever
encounter an integral
of this type,
since it's different than
just using a Feynman parameter
trick.
And that difference comes
about because this guy
is linear in the loop momentum.
This guy's quadratic.
You have to know how
to deal with that,
so we'll talk about
that next time.